when you win the Grammys are you saying
please don't announce us as winners
where you say that was my shilling
Bessie's 33 million singles and 14
million albums okay let's go for it it
was crazy as I can imagine a lot I can't
give you everything give us a glimpse of
it so don't go n c---seventeen more girl
rated are ready
no I how quickly already feeling the
fame you wish rock and roll at its best
it's twisted though pretty tell about
the coke and drugs and all of all that
that comes with it you mean sparkles fly
like Robin Frank get in yeah yeah they
start screaming in we signed the
contract and then he says never f with
me whoa the Dark Lord came out you went
for it we're just gonna do this song and
we're out we've never performed in front
of them now I'm gonna have you read
between the lines in those four songs is
that your voice then comes the fall what
was your method of recovery after all
this madness I don't think there's not a
story like ours did you ever think you
would make it it's a sweet victory I
know this life meant for me why would
you pair on July it but we got that
table value Taemin give it values
contagious this world of entrepreneurs
we can't on value the haters honey run
homie look what I become I'm the under
one
[Music]
so look there's different kinds of
guests I bring on value tame and some of
them is because I'm curious to learn
from them with their stories some of
them is because of a certain business or
they're entrepreneurs their folks that
have done well but some of them have to
do with my life you know my experiences
today's guest is someone who I would say
for for a two-year period he was he and
his partner Rob for the face of music
everywhere around the world I was in
Germany the first time I heard their
music milli vanilli when you remember
girl you know it's true blame it on the
rain or any of those songs that came out
and so I asked the team I said let's
reach out I'd love to sit down with them
we reached out got ahold of his camp
he's sitting here with me fab thanks for
coming out pleasure to meet you Liam I'm
glad to be here so I got to the stories
so for me I get you know Milli Vanilli
won the first time on the whole scandal
took place and it came out a lot of
people didn't want to listen to the
music it was kind of like don't played
in the car anymore right but for me I
couldn't stop playing it because it was
so ridiculously good I mean you can't
even stop listening to to the point
where my wife and I got married June
26th of oh 9 we gave everybody a CD
everybody that came to our wedding we
gave a CD with 12 songs one of the songs
was girl you know it's true okay so we
got a lot to cover here today again I'm
glad you were able to make it out here
so how's life today well you know I know
typically you go backwards start from
the beginning to now but tell me what's
life like for you today what is life
like for me today it's all about my
legacy
every decisions I make is about my
because I want to leave something behind
you know we're not here forever but
whatever you live you leave behind can
be forever and also can be used forever
so as I walk through my book of life
because you know we all have a library
you know life is like to me like this
library right there and each book is a
part of that journey
life is the library and in each books
you know we go through struggles and
maybe the book after then inside 2020 we
learned from a previous book mm-hmm and
then the next book after that or chapter
becomes really really really interesting
because the fact that now what doesn't
kill you makes you stronger what you
learn from makes you better faster
stronger so that's a great way to go
right into one of the first chapters
before today's chapter because sometimes
in life some chapters are the most
painful one and some of them are the
most rewarding one just let's talk about
the chapter before it became the
absolute rewarding everything was going
good for you
who was if you and I were in high school
together you know and we're in school
I'm talking 16 years old 17 years old
who was fat fat was a you know
introverted introverted into art I grew
up in France Paris so you know you have
this beautiful city and then in school
you know we you know that they take you
to museums you know so they connect you
to art and traveling was really
something that interests me music was
was my lifeline even at what age did
music become your lifeline as long as I
can remember
it's been it's been part of part of me
like Bob Marley and because the weather
was so ugly in Paris so going out
because you know the weather has changed
mm-hmm the weather is not what it used
to be and growing up in Paris winters
were hard long summer work you know we'd
go to the Caribbean see my family but it
was harsh environment so staying home
music was the lifeline were you playing
were you listening what was listening I
like it was like the escape
you know it took me somewhere else and I
realized that it took me somewhere else
and then after a while I was like you
know I should definitely find out what
they're talking about because I'm French
guy so I had to take a diction a
dictionary and back then records had a
lot of notes and who recorded what who
sang what so that really became like a
really interesting part of like my life
finding out who did what and then when
you look on one record and you look at
another record then you see that oh
there's the same players who played on
that record and on that record you're
paying attention to the details get to
the details and very detail and that's a
time when there is no YouTube there's no
Wikipedia there's no Google there's
nothing so you have to do all this
research for you you have to
so where are you getting your info you
just go into the record store go to the
register I got you know and then you
read the back you know and before there
was all that information that was there
for you to see you know but there was
part part accident because I was looking
for the lyrics but then you look at
lyrics and then later on in the booklet
then you fell upon who played what so
then once I'm past lyrics then I go
check the you know who did one and there
was an alumni of studio musicians at the
time especially the records that I grew
up with you know from like the 70s to
the 80s all those it was the killers who
named some of them or not oh I can't
remember now any friends like artists no
no no they were American artists
American art you know like I was into
American music so you tell me like some
of the music that we're talking about
are you were talking I like even for
like animals you're talking about all
these sixteen no no no I'm talking about
when I got into the the jacksons five
into Michael Jackson God and and the
earth wind fire and and the James Brown
and then the funk like the cool in the
gang and and oh and the Stevie Wonder's
and Erika Franklin and and all that you
know I realized that there was it was
like a pyramid there was the artist and
then there was like a whole story behind
it yeah it was a whole team of people
like I was like wow
we're curious about that at that age
though that was just an accident
oh that was accident yeah because I was
looking at the lyrics God and then from
lyrics you look in the booklet and it is
like you know keyboard by written by
guitars produced by played by and that
was like oh is that I had to go to
dictionary produced by you know what
that meant so that's when I realized
that you know when you when the record
was made you know it looked like it was
flat but no it was like a full city of
things you know and then distributed by
that's what entrancing so so so from at
this point are you singing are you
modeling in high school
are you dead doing anything that has to
do with I was saying high school I was
always at the beginning you know when
you start singing when you're a singer
you try to you try to grab on to what
you're listening to and you know from
not being able to speak English he just
sang you know he just sing sing sing
sing sing but he don't instantly singing
he or you might not know the right words
are you playing musical instruments are
you organized came from our family I
came from a family of musicians
my grandfather was our canoe accordion
his player so that's why I got into like
you know and I've told that story like I
watched him play his instruments with a
band and I watched my parents transform
into like children and to me they were
always like the father figure you know
mother and father always tricked in on
us and then I noticed that that element
music when it came around people and
people were drinking and but the music
at this power like almost like magic so
when you brought that magic you become
he became the magician and when that
brought the magic you became the
magician yeah and then like that yeah
the for me I was like water sintra and
people became happy like you know I
don't know what what opera with the the
flute ancient flute and he plays and
every way goes people smiling and happy
and that's what it was for me you know
instant joy caught your attention
yeah huh and I was like let's be cool my
mom was like no she don't want you to be
a part of it at all no not you are you
at this point partying a lot with girls
are you partying are you playing sport
you're doing any that support not yet
yeah he's always doing that trampoline I
was doing trampoline I was doing spores
soccer and all that and are you the guy
in high school that's got all the girls
or not yet no not yet
hasn't happened yet no that was more of
a bookworm okay archeology you were
warned yeah was into I music that is
such an interesting archaeology was my
thing like the Incas their calendar that
was for me like whoa like they created a
different you know a you math guy or no
I wasn't math guy but the math teacher
was mean I I'm with you so I think that
I would have gone towards like science
but because math guy was so mean and I
think he was older and he was not and
there was a change in education I was
taking place people it was they were
teaching differently but that guy was
from the old school
that you see that a lot you know
somebody who was actually good in math
but the teacher makes the kid not like
math and you see that with a lot of
different subjects by the way so okay so
now you're in high school you're kind of
getting your feet wet you're liking
music your grandpa played you know some
instruments and you're seen parents get
happy to become like child like when
they listen to music and they're being
entertained it's almost like magic for
you where does that go to you meeting
Rob what is that it connection between
you and Rob hey I'm meeting Rob well I I
was tired of being in Paris you know
always I thought that there was
something more I thought that life was
just I believe there was more and
traveling would provide me with that
adventure so I went with some friends
Germany and Leonard there and and we met
you met Robin German yeah hey Robin
Germany and
there were not many during that time
there were not many dark-skinned people
in Germany in Munich okay especially in
Munich this is where we went and it was
were like adversary' I was on his turf
I was new to the city and he was
wondering who's that guy you know and I
was wondering who's that guy and they
were going out with the same girls
hearing from each other so we're
definitely like around each other's turf
now
and I was looking to join forces with
someone because I was in a new city I
didn't speak German even though I
studied German in school for two years
and kept going to the library to keep my
skills up you know but because I had to
get better you know in order to turn
this know what they were saying but I
kept that to myself and but I in so when
Rob and I met there was certain
camaraderie between you and Rob yeah
there was certain like tongue-in-cheek
like competitive and I thought that's
kind of cool you know III I saw through
or read through the lines and I thought
maybe be cool to hang in and because I
was looking for for friendship was the
opposite personality of you yeah yes
yeah cuz you're very calm you come
across very calm
she'll easygoing and was he more the you
know hothead a little bit fight yeah he
was two years older to almost like an
older brother
yeah was an older brother you know and
but we had that yin and yang vibe you
know and again music was what we loved
so music brought the two of you guys
yeah now what was the connection when
you guys kind of came together was what
was the story do you remember the first
time where you guys are like hey man you
know I still got to know him yeah yeah I
saw him break dance onstage at a party
and he was really good my I was like man
I do dislike and I met him I met him
like a few days before and then um there
was a girl at the dance school and this
girl is like oh there's a party you
should go is that really cool and ice
so that's at that place and then I saw
him there as well so it was the
interview in the amount of a couple of
days you know I ran into him and he was
on stage and he was doing his thing and
I see was done with his routine
he looked at me like you know like he
was a breakdancer so it was you know the
stare you know he gave me the stairs I
was like alright what you won't you tell
them that no nobody was like I was what
what is he doing you know I was thinking
but you know it I was like it's cool
it's cool I did we didn't know who we
were to each other yet you know but I've
felt like there was a certain connection
he was cool and he was very good at what
he did and what happened is the approach
you he did you go to him and no no no it
won't make you guys good yeah it
happened organically you know we just
ran into each other from time to time
you know and it would call me a star I
was like okay star no then I would next
time with a star and inch inch by inch
we got closer to each other by just this
competitive and you know thing but he
was a loner just like I was because he
was always he was always alone I was
always alone so that's why I questioned
I was like that's weird because he's
always alone in movies alone so maybe
together you know we can be stronger
together at that time I didn't know that
he was into music as much as I was you
know but when we kid we got together
then we realized that maybe you should
we should do something together about
music because one of the first time we
talked together we talked about music
what you liked and Rob played guitar and
played a few Blues chords as well you
know so at some point we started
experimenting with like okay he plays
guitar we played we wrote some songs and
it was an organic process organic
process yeah that's that's and by the
way we
you too in Munich the only to like you
know blacks that you knew in Munich at
the time like was it because I remember
here's what I remember I went into the
army I went to Fort Campbell Kentucky it
was only me and another guy who was from
the Middle East okay so when you spot
another Middle Eastern and you're Middle
Eastern guess what you're gonna become
best friends yes because we got
something to catch my that's fast
everybody would look at us in yeah why
are these guys from Iran in the US Army
this is very weird so we had immediately
a lot in common the bomb was that the
bond for the two of you yeah it was that
it definitely because especially the
places we were hanging out what we hung
out I mean there was none no no no and
if you know if you know Germany deliver
to you okay so the Varia is the most one
of the most conservative area in Germany
so dad that yeah you you you depicted
well you know yeah because of that bond
there was no one who is looking like us
now was there a lot of military bases
already cuz I know Rob's dad was from
the Air Force
yeah there was a lot of base during that
time okay so because a lot of soldiers
in the army always wanted to go to
Germany because when you went to Germany
Germany was known for partying it was a
place to go and and German women were
all into partying and you know at the
time so when it came down to orders
every soldier would have a list so what
would you like to you want to go to Camp
Casey Korea
no you want to go to Okinawa Japan maybe
do you want to go to over here I want to
go to Germany tonight and and even for
me I lived it from 10 to 12 I gotta tell
got nothing but good memories when I was
in Germany for a young boy early age I
said you know I was having fun at a very
young age in Germany a good time yeah
so you're meeting Rob you guys are you
know going out together now at this
point you're experimenting is playing
the guitar you were trying some music
together how does that lead to you now
meeting Frank how does that introduction
take place well because you know we're
trying to do our thing in the city of
Munich and we were connected to some two
musicians which we were playing soccer
with during the summer okay and you know
people started to you know and we did a
few gigs at
a club copy is and from there people
started to mention our names you know
and that was what we were trying to do
with trying to create a wave of
awareness about all those guys and we're
always at peons you know putting the
vibes in the club so to make sure
everyone knew that we do exist and we
could possibly lead to connecting to the
right people because this club was was
full of influential people you know it
was and determined it was financed
sewers there was all kinds of worlds
merging together a little bit I was a
small club okay but the crowd was was a
lot of wealthy got enriched yeah you
know yeah what's the name of the club P
is P I it's like one yeah yeah he let
her like Peter yeah and one and and that
would that Club was inside house a kunst
house a kunst is um was a museum the
club is in the museum yeah the clubs in
museum but because sick what was it like
a legit clot was it a you know happening
place to go to I was having things I
hope it's very difficult know you could
only fit I think four hundred us it's
not a big club it's decent size a decent
size but small and cramped but it was
influential the right beer I mean I've
seen there I've seen bono there III saw
Whitney Houston performed there woman a
record get like I mean I saw and met so
many people there that I met after the
fact we said you guys are you in that
club too fun yeah I met Charlie Wilson
there too you know I met so many artists
who remembered us because we used to
bring the vibe mm-hmm we made sure like
people were dancing and that was just
like instinct you know if I could say
like that instinct make people dance
like push the vibe
yes we wanted to connect with people but
the music had such a powerful effect
when you Marcel or no were you guys
singing it or no no no no no I haven't
performed yet
nein so what was the first time you guys
did a perform together on stage wasn't P
on see that Club what song was it it was
some Beatles song some soul song what
was that one again about you a diamond
ring my friend I forgot the name in that
one you know Beatles songs in and others
I can't remember right now you know but
it was a we felt that we were born to do
this and there was that camaraderie of
being able to be in a place and just
take over so when it came time to end up
on stage you know that that natural
chemistry that we have and sparkle then
we would like you know two energies
coming together papa then it was like
action reaction and then rock the circle
yeah between the audience and so we had
that thing packed down because we had
been performing together on stage doing
some shows and singing no we had done we
came from like a dancing we're doing
some shows and from there what we had
learned as performers like this then
with the singing and being came together
you know got it so you guys were natural
performers that national party your
natural performers and and trying to get
the right because you know like I said
from a young age I've learned that
there's a pyramid you know yet the the
singing of from but yet the songwriters
mmm you got the producers and that's was
we were after that when did you meet
Frank oh not good with dates oh did you
meet him at the Pew yeah no no no but
through through our work yeah you know
through creating this wave of awareness
that's how we got connected to some of
the people who worked with him and then
and we were brought up and then after
the connection was made and then we
ended up you know it is at his studio
what we do so is this like 87 86 87 88
the magic Kamala is much better with
with those states who is the manager
your managers better today yeah let's
just say in the late 80s you end up with
your head up meet a mid to late 80s end
up meeting Frank first time you meet
Frank was it in Germany or you met him
in Germany in Germany yeah he's coming
out
no no Frankfurt in Frankfurt yeah so you
meet Frank the first time in Frankfurt
how was that the first introduction here
to him I mean oh you walk in in in his
man studio was nothing but like cold
records on the on the walls and you know
he had four studios filled with like SSL
Neve councils consoles and those were
back then
super expensive so each room was filled
with rat like you know like people make
music at a computer today but like the
wall behind you was filled with rack
mounts like from like this and like this
and then the so this is the back and
that way this is the console the
speakers are here that counts the counts
the console of like maybe 90 tracks on
there and the walls of fall so when you
come in this room you can feel it's
soundproof so when you enter the room
you feel like of course a lot of
electricity in the room but it's it's
like you come in you can feel like this
silence before music plays you can you
feel like wow what is that like that's a
spaceship that's like you're about to
fly in this and everything looks very
futuristic so very attractive very he
had four of those he had four of those
and this is in the late 80s so he spent
some money on that oh because he made a
lot of money so at that time did you
know who he was like did you know he was
naughty knowing names that he had I
didn't know he was demand behind bone am
because me
Mia was a French kid who grew up on lots
of music and and I knew buddy em you
know Bonilla yeah yeah okay so you
listen to the music yeah okay that was
not my favorite but I grew up on it and
I knew it because we had parties you
know young kids go to parties in those
songs were always played always they
were played in my house every day I mean
I know those four main songs we were
talking about daddy cool Sammy and my
baby and then was rest between respite
in yes right so you knew he represented
them at that time was he with 19 now or
you didn't have no no okay Rob Rob told
me like you know you know this guy did I
was like oh really I was like wow so my
eyes were like boo really loved me that
guy was like okay cool you know I didn't
know about the controversy behind it
because that had come out as well so you
didn't know that that was a play that he
followed in the past but no high tea at
all because I was already accessible
super-sick said I think a hundred and
twenty million records yeah I mean till
today most people don't even know that
even till today people don't know that
because you know the you know you came
at an era where news popped out very
quickly when somebody was you know
became famous quickly you can rise and
you can fall very quickly but the the
era of boney m when they were doing it
things could kind of just slide with a
couple different things so it's okay so
you're sitting with them what was your
impression you know when when you first
came in did he give you more attention
was he talking to rob more not was he
giving both of you respect he was uh
he's very smart men so he was trying to
understand the dynamics between Rob and
I and maybe possibly already because you
know because he's a smart man because he
the way constructed his business because
there's a business of some of the music
business eyesight 20/20 when I analyze
him now and since seeing what he had in
his compound like four rooms filled with
people they were not empty there were
people teams working in there
so he built this whole thing so when it
comes to planning and orchestrating I'm
I was sitting across a maestro not
understanding that at all I was a naive
kid I saw this man father figure that we
trusted automatically because of the
fact that look what he built I mean
obviously he is the owner of this thing
in front of the houses m1a Beamer is
very rare so that costs a lot of money
too so this guy you know in our eyes
he's the man in your eyes he's the man
so you're never you know as it reflects
you know you're not gonna bite the hand
that wants to feed mm-hmm so you play
like hey whatever let me know how high
is it charming is he charming is he
charismatic or no he's more subtle quiet
yes he loud what's his approach with you
he was just calm you know like you
appear to be nice like like like father
figure you know and but it was busy you
know so he came in we met we were
introduced to somebody else who talked
with us later the encounter was short
because he was busy first encounter was
short well wasn't that long 30 minutes
20 minutes I can't remember right now
because I you know the I didn't speak
German and tell you well so Robert yeah
so rob mostly and didn't speak English
very much and I can't remember how long
it was I'm just curious to know like
when the first time you met him was it
getting to know you was it straight
going into business with them no no
because what they were they just wanted
to meet us okay you know so that's the
first minute or yeah you just want to
meet us and and fill it out what happens
after that we went we went back to two
Nick you know and we got back to cut
back in touch with us and say yeah we're
gonna come together it was like okay
cool you know and then time went by time
went by we never heard from them you
know I were wondering like well what's
going on what's going on but I think
that in the meantime Frank had
implemented something into motion you
know he found those two guys that he was
only interested in for one reason their
voice no no he was not interested into
our voices no no you said two guys or he
talked about Charles rotella you and Rob
Rob and I okay got it
you know inside 20/20 because I don't
know what was going on he's in mind I
have no idea today but when I put the
puzzle back together and hear from
others I think that it found one in the
main piece of this puzzle
and then from there just like building a
pyramid you started building he built it
you know music and then when it was time
for us to come to the studio he had this
track going it was true without vocals
which we thought like okay Stanley shine
but the time the shine never came really
we were never asked to show what we had
never we've never performed in front of
him he never asked and we were like okay
when is he gonna you know when he's
gonna ask us you know because we thought
that we were gonna come to the studio
and then certainly there was a track hmm
there was no vocals on there and I said
it before if I would have known how a
console worked I would have seen that
they were mute buttons because you know
when back then they were they there was
a tape along the console and there you
you have like guitar bass keys vocals
lead vocals backgrounds harmonies
everything is written handwritten you
know
if I would have known about this process
well I would have known that there was
there was something about this that was
muted you know so in this room you know
we were like wow look at the studio when
hearing the instrumental being played I
mean we saw ourselves on stage you saw
yourself on stage yeah we said wow this
is a great track we could do this like
it was first time you heard girl you
know it's true
yeah and so this is means this is not
the original obviously girl you know
it's true that didn't do that well
because I think there was another person
that yeah I knew marks new marks yeah it
works and I didn't know about new marks
you add that I have no idea who knew
mark says you don't know girl you know
it's true
no but I just heard it was instrumental
right I didn't hear it was just a music
he played as music that's right that's
all you've heard yeah okay so you so
you're sitting at your first listening
to the instrumental you haven't heard
the the voice yet you know when is the
voice being introduced you how I came
later so from there because I've told
the story right from this this room that
was of Jose in French we say - did that
also Lee meaning everything was like
sunny and happy and you know Wow
everything is green palm trees if I can
describe it like that you know like if
you speed up an image of trees and
flowers growing the jungle like is
something positive is happening and then
from that room we went to another room
and in that room there was like a dark
cloud that came and started raining and
pouring and storm came in
you felt it immediately yeah I was weird
it was like from one happy and then even
his face because I've always because I
didn't speak English German very well or
English I relied on body language which
I'm in library econo kind of looked into
that so I could analyze people from the
way they would behave
and it was a drastic like he was
different he was different in the other
room
yeah so you're going the other one what
does he say to you all I talks to to to
rob in German and then I can see I know
Rob I can see him just fuming like
getting mad and I was like whoa how can
it be how can it be not good it was all
good and not so bad it feels like so I
mean patient I want to find out what's
going on you know and he get into it and
sparkles fly Frank leaves I'm like oh
that can't be good you mean sparkles fly
like Robin Frank get in yeah yeah they
start screaming in you know you know rob
is not happy and I'm not getting it you
know cuz it did they were speaking fast
Frank leaves and then Rob's turns to me
and tells me that and I can't really
recall you know I'm paraphrasing but
pretty much he tried to explain to me
that they don't want us to sing on this
and I'm like dumbfounded I'm trying to
understand like I don't get it
in the meantime before all that we'd
signed the contract a recording contract
and received a little bit of advance but
we we you know we when we signed those
papers there was no attorneys there was
no managers there's no support system we
were just like eager-beaver
where how high should I jump got it this
is when you got $1,500 that's right is
it fifteen hundred a piece or fifteen
hundred total I can't recall a maybe a
piece okay so nothing crazy no no no
maybe like get up just enough to go get
some clothes work on that hair you know
cuz we had braids did he suggest you go
work on the hair no no no no that was
over here Rizal you and Rob
yeah okay you thought about them yeah
everybody wanted to have a unique look
so you want to have a unique look so
that's right okay got it so and then he
comes you talk rob is furious him and
Frank go at it and then at what point so
he's already told them what he has a
mine here's a song I'm gonna get the
voice you guys will be the performers
you'll be the face but someone's going
to be
so he told that to rob yeah in English
not paraphrasing paraphrasing but he
just won't listen you guys be two-faced
that's it yeah you know that's that's it
and that's why we were like that makes
no sense so we came we signed a contract
we got some money but through the months
of absence of their absence to us and
contacts we ran out of money so hey can
we get some more also what up said no
we're not gonna do it is what I'm
assuming yeah okay so Robinson we're not
doing this yeah yeah yeah then you
running out of money then you reach out
it not know until before before for what
I'm trying to say when we went Gloria
knows who has played to us this time
period that you were asking so what
happened mhm that time period when we
first get that first money we asked for
some more through the months hirato
that added up who yet appear ranch we
thought things would be moving a lot
quicker so we there's not timeline is
that six months is that yours at three
months remember exactly okay
a manager we'd know baby you know okay
but it was but we had to survive during
that time that we thought it would go
quick and but he was not coming and
maybe it was part of the plan so yeah
give him more because they'll be
indebted so after a while was through
man mounting a certain amount of money
that we there was not a lot but to pay
that back let me take some time and so
you guys don't want to do it so pay us
back like Oh
that means we'd have to maybe get a job
get some more shows but how do we get
that money like you know because now we
owe this person is very powerful person
and maybe if we don't do what what we're
supposed to do we might never get a
chance to get an industry again you know
says it was all that that was going on
so you know we went to the hotel and
thought about it and then we went for it
you went for it yeah thinking but we
went for it saying okay we're just gonna
do this song and we're out we pay you
back like that and from there you know
we got it tasteful for that that life
we had nothing so certainly you know you
travel you're on the road so so let's
back up so you go back to the hotel you
decide okay let's go for yeah so then
you go for it how quickly did things
move there where the song was built you
guys do music video what what happened
next no I think what what happened is
like when was the song when we agreed we
did like a a small video at a TV station
and so we had to come up with a cog Rafi
and learn the song and all that and that
was on a small station for a certain
part of Germany and I think maybe in the
airplane it was a test to see if people
would react and I think that this little
thing that we had done this test the
results came back real good real good
really good God and from there that's
like the song started to to get some
action and then we were cold and this
time we did a video so so the music
video that we see of girl you know it's
true is that has that already been
producer not yet not yet not yet not yet
so
what was the song that he tested and
that won't smaller noise true it is girl
you know it's true yeah okay and have
you met the voices yet you know at all
no no I I wasn't aware of the
construction of this thing we had no
idea how it worked how we came about who
was behind so when your when you did the
first video that they tested was that
video you lip sing and in that video
just performing at this video that's it
I got it so you're doing the dancing
you're doing the performing listen the
instrumental playing in the background
so and and the song is written by the
folks who knew Marx or whatever they're
called they're not even involved I don't
know about that okay listen are they
involved with Frank or you wouldn't know
til today
meaning that Frank buy the rights to the
writing of that so I I think that you
know what you in music business you just
you know you just you know okay we're
using your song their rights drugs no
every writer is protected so you know
they got paid obviously so Frank have to
pay the writer yeah yeah I've got
through royalties god it's automatic
sure okay I've got it
it's a is like he he took his song it's
like a cover it's a cover but you know
he took it to do do you know nothing yet
that it's a cover you know nothing of no
idea so that that song they come back
the results are good they're like and it
they bring you back to now do a video
together a real video a real video like
serious of like nada
actually there's a section of like the
film industry in Munich
back in the 80s was they were doing some
movies that were made in 80's were made
in that's pivara studio and there we did
this this video you know the first one
so part of it was filmed there and the
another part was filmed in London but we
were part now of a very professional
entity we could see it like becoming
they're closing in on us and okay this
is great we were tasting and being
seduced by this whole thing because you
know from having nothing to be involved
with like professional people and
you know living your dream you know when
you live your dream and you testing it
you know it's not but we can taste it
all the way not yet
yeah I mean and I mean not all the way
in the sense that we're not singing
so you tasting it but you know you're
showing mm-hmm you're chewing but you
can't really taste it let me end it
describe it like that let me ask you
this so while at this point the first
test not the big video that you did the
first test did you get attention like
that people locally say oh my gosh no no
we do nothing crazy no no no no it's
they that was their case study got it
sing all very small case they smoked it
so now they do the big video the main
one they spent some money into the body
we had to do it because it was moving so
when something is moving well now we got
a you know they got to go full-on and of
course of course so that's the business
that's the timing is there anything in
the video that's your voice so you know
the beginning us as well I sat back and
thought about mom used to you it really
meant a lot to me that's not that so
that's also the voice of Charles or
whoever they will yeah okay yeah so so
you're simply you know acting and
performing the entire thing from the
beginning tender with the video so now
the video comes out okay he launches it
at what point was the tipping point
where it just took off it took off
really fast because suddenly you had
Robin fab and the music and they both
did this because he built it like that
you know his face it's without Frank
none of that would have been possible so
this plan this puzzle that he was
implementing in order for his puzzle to
come to life first installments was
working and it was going up the charts
and he was moving fast let me let me ask
you this while it's moving fast are you
and Rob behind closer saying I hope it
slows down a little bit because we don't
want to get too much attention we kind
of don't mind getting some attention but
we don't want to
a lot of attention from this yeah we
were definitely we definitely had that
feeling because we were thinking okay
one record this is not gonna go you know
you know we were when we heard this on
the first I was like yeah but then you
know we went to the other room and had
to deal with the fact that okay we are
thinking we're working to get out not to
get deeper in you know so when you guys
are speaking the plan is to leave this
thing you don't want yeah we don't want
to stay there but you know we we naive
sign the contract that was I think for
like three hours or something but we
signed we only if I recall perfectly
there was only a few pages that were
that we were signing but on the other
side of it you know I it was part of the
much bigger contract my god your sense
of God but we didn't get that and you
know of course you know eventually it
came out like hey what are you going you
know we thought where are you going
no no you got more to do and then it was
that I could there was that battle
because it sound good you know but
obviously it was wrong but the other
side of the coin you can't get out
because you got three more to go
oh yeah you got three more albums to go
not even songs it's about its albums and
you know you got money you know so that
it was well designed it was well played
and we were not even didn't know how to
and no protection no attorneys no still
nothing
no enough manager agent attorney nothing
yeah I think they were okay so when it
took off it did he now start paying you
some kind of royalty are you making a
little bit more money now or not yet
well the way was designed is like you
know you're on the road you got food you
you dialed 9 I want this this and this
and then certainly
20 minutes later your table is full so
you know you you you you know we were
money at that point was not really part
of our equation our equation was music
making people happy
doing what we loved that was you know
that's the youth the youth doesn't think
yeah about the distraction consequences
you know every decisions you make their
consequences to what you did to it you
take how quickly already feeling the
frame oh you feel it because you can we
perform on TV shows and then certainly
consider the curves are coming not that
we had any problems with girls at the
time but you could feel like wow we're
becoming like pop stars and it's very
seductive about because you you know
you're young man and part of the young
man's life is consumed by simple things
girls music dancing enjoying life you
know a butterfly mm-hmm
you know but we were we're flying close
to a flame had no idea you know what a
butterfly for me flies you know full
force no thinking and once we were
caught into this girl know his true
storm of energy you know because it's
it's pure energy this thing that you get
back from the fans it's intense its
addicting
once you're addicting to that that vibe
you know then it's yeah it pulls on you
not about so what song came next after
that how quickly did you do the rest
oh they had it planned as a matter of
fact that they were while this was going
they were working on the rest the teams
like that whole compound was burning
rubber I thought they were going at it
you know and baby do forget my number
and then blame it on the rain go I'm
gonna miss you if I recall the orders
because suddenly there was Europe but
then America come into play and when
America is starting to like calling your
name it changes everything because
America was we dreamt about going to
America Los Angeles New York first time
you ever came to America when was it
1989 I believe so this is after the four
hits are out oh no no no no no we came
for good noise true or you came so you
shot the video here in London we shot in
London and in Germany if I recall
correctly he had parts of it in Germany
Munich and part of it in London but then
as things were rising high in the charts
in Europe they already had made a plan
of course you know it's a business let's
not forget there's music and there's the
business of this business so they will
make him moves all that I found out some
of it later on but they were talking to
wrecked companies abroad you know
especially in New York with Ariston I
record so you come to LA when you came
to LA did you get a lot of firsts first
week we went to New York first ok you
went to New York
auntie MTV so you do that did you tell
me what it was like like that was crazy
as I can't imagine what yeah what yeah
because you know we I remember we came
in that Sun was going down we're on the
freeway and the museum picked up in a
limousine
you know like late eighties you know
like the lone ones not a town car
limousine Cadillac like in the movies
and I went in the United States so it
was like you know a world that we saw on
the screen was now in front of us you
know I remember watching the cars drive
and in my mind watching movies the cars
always made noise you know like it was
like boom they're not making noise cuz
overdubs you know so we were looking at
it
total different reality through movies
and now we were in like New York City
the city that never sleeps so we drive
down we see the city and we turn the
radio and we hear go nose through on
several stations - it's like so it's
like it was like a shot of adrenaline
like you can't even explain that it's
just like wow and then in the airport
you know people recognize you oh you
know New York style you know it was
overwhelming and you go down to New York
and no hotel go to MTV and he and you
realize every way you go you like the
mayor everybody wants to uh I didn't
have phones like that back then but you
know sign of the graphs so just
autographs / selfies back then yeah yeah
that's right sense and also there were
only a few news outlets like wank
so whenever a news work was dropped into
those those various news outlet that was
it you couldn't contest none of what was
going through there the powers that be
and the gatekeepers were connected to
those to those outlets so you were you
know you were handcuffed you were
controlled you know controlled yes so so
New York LA you're getting all the fame
all the you know vibes you're you're
you're getting it going at what point
did you know what Frank did with Bonilla
Bonilla at what point did you realize
that did anybody come and tell you that
or did you kind of reveal it yourself I
can't remember I came about but it was
brought to tea to to our attention I
can't remember how I found out but I did
and it was only one person he did the
voice of Bobby Farrell and I thought I
was weird I was like well what he didn't
he you know
and then I then it was this whole
curtain you know there's something that
would be something that was hidden like
you know the the Invisible Man
you know the potion is gone suddenly
well the true face because he was
looking a certain way to us but then
another face came up so what I mean by
Invisible Man it was a man in front of
us but there was another invisible side
to him you mean behind Frank or behind
Bobby Oh behind Frank
Brad Frank well and when I when I found
out about the fact that he had done with
Bobby Ferrell then it was two person in
one a very a man with a plan
very strategic you know nothing was made
by accident
premeditated did you confront him about
it we had fights we had fights about it
about bogna about the the his approach
not his approach but what what he was
doing to us because we were trying to
sing did you at all bring it up to him
that saying you did this with Boneham
you don't want to I don't want you to no
no that never came to bone iam never was
no no no he's never brought up like I
was so focused on on on our is our
situation was to we wanted to sing
mm-hmm on the second single that was
like like yo this is going we want to go
but obviously and I've spoke about that
before in our minds we thought we could
okay now it's time you sing because with
the first single you go in okay we'll
get out oh no we're not getting out now
we gotta keep going
but you can't sing now like oh wow like
it was just like we're getting punched
by reality is he threatening behind
closed doors like is he saying things
like if you guys think about leaving me
I'm going to tell everybody that you
guys don't know how to sink no you're
not singing
nobody we were forewarned I remember
when I when I when we
signed the contract it was all nice
again just like the studio the song is
playing go to the next room we signed
the contract and then he says to never F
with me like like whoa the Dark Lord
came out like what Darth Vader was
something set for him to say that or no
no no no it was just he was done like it
was out of nowhere and that's when my
radar just went like oh that's kind of
weird like why would he say that
you know I guess now we signed so don't
ever try to cross me but he didn't say
if you go and try to leave me I'm gonna
no no no nothing nothing give him that
but I hear no no because we like you
know he was a probably what he did you
know he let us we felt its power so as
we were fighting against each other
we had no we realized we had no power
hmm
so we didn't know what to do at this
point we had no support system to help
us make a proper decision you know if
there would have been an attorney to
protect us in a manager to work together
and say listen Frank we know you want
them let's do it let's do it properly
from the beginning you know but we had
nobody we didn't know how the music
business worked did you did you ask him
we're gonna go get on agent a manager
did you ever tell that to Frank or no no
we never got into that as well or never
because let me ask you from the moment
of you you know the girl you know it's
true being tested in a small market to
the point of it coming out being public
that it wasn't your voice what is the
time line they're talking two years
maybe two years yeah because you know
when's Gary knows who went there was the
next and the next and the next
and then Europe was catching fire and
America was catching fire how many
records got sellout this time what kind
of what kind of numbers I think the
total by now might be more it's 33 sing
of 30 33 million singles and 14 million
albums in this 2 years yeah 33 million
same singles in two years
14 million albums yeah because you get
in America we need 7 and the rest of the
world so think about this and this is at
a time there is no iTunes there is no
$0.99 buck 29 nice so if you want one
song you can buy the single if you want
but you gotta buy the album if you want
three four yes right and albums were not
running nine bucks or eight bucks you
pain yeah 15 bucks so they made you know
they made well for themselves as a
matter of fact you know Clive Davis was
able to with that to create some other
entities I know he's a businessman of
course you make money you grow you're
gonna create more to create more money
so at this - during this two-year period
33 million singles 40 million album
which is crazy are you making millions
at this point are you guys making tens
of millions of dollars or not yet
no no because it was designed from the
start that contract was not vetted by
anyone so we just signed something that
was just like you know the line share
was taken by the man and we just got
like describes and that was also shared
with the people who sang on the record
are you making a few hundred thousand
dollars per year are you making a
million dollars per year now are you
living in a nice house do you have a
nice car or you can try private do you
have a private jet line no we didn't do
private jets back then no at all so
you're not yet living in a big house no
because we're always on the road so
you're saying that hotels the entire
time yeah they made us work we did we
did a hundred and seven cities in eight
months
[Laughter]
you know so you know so like I said you
know they they were they were pulling
the strings you know and how that's the
two years go by it fell those two years
felt like five years really because it
was just what do you mean three years
felt like five years it was so so much
was crime that when I look back I'm
drunk that's too weak when people say
you know you were here from there to
there and I'm like really like it was
just like surreal surreal and every any
darts stories experiences like
encounters of people and like I'm like
when I was two years of my life how much
are you party like meaning are you with
a different girl every day every night
is it you know is it that like are you
partying hardcore where there's five
girls at the hotel waiting for you and I
mean first of all when you look at the
pictures I got to tell you you know two
extremely handsome good-looking guys
okay you got robbed who looks you know
with his eyes and the color and then you
got you you got the whole you know the
jaw perfect structure going on how crazy
was though it was it was crazy nom and
you know they're people that probably
families and people watching so I can go
really in detail but it was rock and
roll at its best not its finest give us
a glimpse of it so don't go nc-17 but go
rated are ready though i okay you get
back you you get offstage backstage we
made sure that the room was filled when
the room is filled we take it back to
base go back to base because we were
organized army like when he came to
partying when they say back to base your
said back to base back to hotel or back
daughter that's the base but the base
has different levels in areas so you
bring back everybody to one spot and
then because you know the place where
people are gonna end up it's not it's
not that big so you now you have to
scream you have to screen who can't or
scream yeah scream so there's a
filtering process a testing process and
then they go to another room yeah
so it's well denies until until you know
the goal of that was to you know he want
to get the best because at that time for
us you know you you flying high you know
life is extremely intense and it's about
because the stage you know the the
adrenaline that you get is so intense
you want to keep this feeling going
so the show must go on and this lasted
every day for pretty much two years
always crazy and intense that's intense
where he's intense intense I mean and in
the process you know you you know you
you know like I said rock and roll comes
with certain elements the dark element
and when you start to play around with
those elements
hence butterflies the flame you know you
will open some wormholes and you might
not come back from those are you talk
about the coke and drugs and all of all
that that comes with it of course all of
it yeah because you don't know what you
playing with at this point and it's
every day yeah yeah even though the
thing is we were so strong physically
sometimes I wonder how we worried about
you like you know show party parties
show and we used to also exercise how
many have to sleep you're getting at
this time when you pee when you at your
peak the hundred and seven and eight
months
[Music]
six or you are getting your rest yeah we
had to yeah yeah yeah that's good
sometime when you're on an upper it's
kind of tough to oh yeah so yeah but we
had to because we you know you party it
up then people have to leave you gotta
leave so when you go to the next city
you got your own bus gotta y'all get
your own Bank
you know so you that's the rest in time
that's where you recover so this thing's
taking off it's going good two years
momentum rock and roll the whole nine
what was the moment I mean you win one
award
then you go to Grammys you win the
Grammy Award when you win the Grammys
and you have that in your hand you're
giving your speech you're walking off
what are you guys telling each other
like when they're announcing are you
saying please don't announce us as
winners well you say that was my feeling
and you know I mean you know the awards
you know how it works you know that the
recipients is moved up so they they come
get you now you're sitting the front
like yeah that's like you know you get
like a little uncomfortable because you
know you know what's coming and it's
like you know this thing that's like
about to blow up because we in the event
that this thing happens you're gonna get
a lot of attention unwanted attention to
us that we really don't want to to have
and I remember robbed in an interview
and that created more attention it was
taken out of context is that the Time
magazine 100 yeah what he says we're
where the writer said yeah we're more
impactful than Paul McCartney yes yes
which was crazy but that brought more
oil to the fight is this pre-grammy or
three people yeah as pre I believe so
yeah if I'm not wrong if I'm not wrong
because you know it's a lot to remember
and it happens I don't know I'm going up
those stairs I was like whoa
I remember like the Koya I like my hand
just went into if I was a superhero like
I would have broke that chair like in
silk right I would have transformed into
that dude right there because it was
like no way no way meaning please don't
call don't I can't believe this has
happened and now because it was like you
know yeah we've received the American
Music Awards I was already one thing but
now you're dealing with the Grammys the
Grammys Narus the whole tradition of I
don't think there's not a story like
ours it's Grammy recipients no never
now you're the only one exactly yeah and
it's a perfect story for a movie but
this is oh yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah and
I know they're working on some kind of a
biopic or I don't know what this stuff
going on man you know like Zillah but
it's show business so you know it has to
be right two teams that that I'll be
working with with a manager oh this
would be a phenomenal story it would be
awesome be a phenomenal story so you go
up you get it you walk off and then what
are you and Rob telling each other when
the cameras are often you guys are just
by yourself you know when you know
someone very well like a family member
you don't need to say nothing it's just
you can feel each other
it's the way you look at each other and
enough said I get it I was like I didn't
know what to say you know as a matter of
fact that I say they live very little
but the little bit that was told that
night by Rob you know when he took the
award and said that listen this is for
any artists out there who's putting the
work because you know we were criticized
but we put in the work you know we went
to work every night gave our best and
anybody that came to see us we killed it
that's one thing for sure
we gave our best to the fans we love the
fans and this is what we wanted to do
you know want to live this this dream
was not the perfect dream far from
partly partly unfortunately you know and
this Grammy receiving this Grammy was
you guys partied that not with any
celebrities were you because you know
Grammys there's a lot of after parties
were you with some names that are saying
hey Karen graduation I know I think that
we went I think we went back to the red
company party but after that had things
to blur it's a blur because it was yeah
yeah we were trying to yeah we're trying
to like medicate ourselves to be numb
and not feel it at all yeah because what
we've been doing it because you know
like there was like I said there was a
lot going on you know we were being
pulled upon and having to keep going
when in fact we didn't want to keep
going let me ask you did anybody from
Bonilla ever reach out to you guys did
you ever talk to Bobby did you ever talk
about those guys because I know they
eventually ended up dropping Bobby Bobby
was one of the ones that couldn't handle
it all right because apparently when he
came out it was tough on them you know
with a for Bobby so they never reached
out to you because they work with Frank
to say hey just kind of be careful they
kind of minded your own business yeah
everybody mind their own business and we
were we were kept at bay from everyone
shielded from each other so lonely so so
I want to play video for you and I want
to get your low blame because this is
this is this is when things start
getting moving pretty quickly I just
want to get your reaction to see when
you watch this now what is your reaction
okay Paul I think you put it up here yes
let me play this for you hang on
[Music]
and the best no young MC
[Applause]
he'll never dislike it was yesterday
yeah
but I know you had to go with it
we had no choice in the moment that we
got the branding what do you think well
when you see that the video obviously
I'm sure you've seen this before but the
video where the girl you know with girl
you know which was that the downfall
after that or not you're not Adele
really no no it was just when we did the
music behind the music it was like it
was made to be that but he wasn't that
at all because we went on to get a
Grammy after that that was the MTV Tour
you see so when I look at the the
footage receiving you know there's a lot
that went on and of course I can't give
you everything you know but I can tell
you a lot when in that night at the
Grammys and it is one thing that maybe
not everything but give us a glimpse
give us one thing that maybe has not
been revealed about that moment and how
quickly it went not all of it we just
went out greedy just give us one of them
know that the one thing is like I mean
we knew we were performing you know that
you know and usually that those were the
hints you know like sitting in the front
because we changed clothes who would
clothes dress differently that night and
then they put you in the front and then
there were shots that were if you look
the Grammys always get the charge like
okay okay they're the focal points Best
New Artist okay okay okay all right
performing okay obviously we we're not
singing live
you know I so you got to take in
consideration that millions of people
are watching the Grammys every year and
I think you expect any nominee to
perform live you know so that whole
thing that was going on and we didn't
know we know was coming
we didn't know we knew didn't know it
was unsure just like a rubber band you
know he pulls it pulls but you don't
know until it breaks and the breaking
point is like and the winner is because
you could have gone differently you know
because I mean we knew that the industry
knew so they didn't know so now I'm
gonna have you read between the lines
it's an industry it's a business it's
ran by very powerful people by
gatekeepers money is the fuel to the
engine of course so people may do the
math when you do the math you realize
hmm all right you know we were like out
of this out of the links with the
smallest link the smallest there were
very powerful people that were pulling
strings and for us to have gone this far
without being hmm we were noticed but
unnoticed about these very specific
major details you gotta ask yourself
some questions the bigger names that
Frank oh yeah man come on like you know
you know and and more and more you know
you can see that some of those those
awards you know is it really ran
properly like you know how those
decisions taken who's in control that's
that's I'm just putting it out there let
me let me another pointing finger I'm
just saying do the math let lets let's
be you know and you have enough we've
been we've been exposed to to to to
those and sometimes you wonder like oh
really I mean you know nowadays Auto
Tunes people can manipulate their voices
oh that's that's a whole other kind of
worm but what I'm saying what I'm saying
to you is to follow it at that time what
happened with you and Rob would what
Frank did using Charles and the other
guys that were you know the the real
singer and in John days yes that's right
it was it was actually the three names
writers yeah Charles Angela Davis and no
John Davis red owl and yeah and then
with boney m with Daddy cool and all
those guys would Bobby were there other
names like that in the past as well was
that was that a way of doing was that
very normal back then well I brought
because it's tough to do that you know
the whole story with Martha Walsh you
know mark the walls yeah yeah where
she's singing it's raining it's raining
man and it blows up that's very well and
and they use her everybody dance now C&C
Music Factory that became a big kid but
the rest wasn't her but that one part
was like wait a minute this is my voice
calls her manager I got to get in front
of it look I want a part of this why are
you not using my it's it's you can't
teach a look do you know what I'm saying
you can't make somebody look like you
and Rob know so you need somebody to be
the face I'm asking if that was a
business model back in a daze pre-social
media days well you guys weren't the
only ones
naughty wise it was a bit was a current
practice current today or then no well
we'll get to that but yeah yes a years a
lot of because you know
because of the world is different now
you know Europeans can't speak English
now very well hmm back then it was none
of that right so they used for example
France there were a lot of famous very
very famous records turned out to be
like lip-synched sang by somebody else
which uh I mean I'm not gonna sing it
but what I know the Lipson there's two
parts for lipstick one is I just don't
feel like I can perform well and I'm
doing the inauguration my name is
Beyonce look I didn't do it that was
listen no no that but back then it was
just a business model because they were
professional producers who were working
with English team or American teams and
they were like okay you know dude if you
want to be international it's got to be
perfect it's got to be like an English
accent American accent so throughout
Europe there were teams that were
working with okay they're French citizen
or they're in Germany do it find the
people who can do the dance it represent
and then there was another team behind
you would do it so it was a common
practice so so let me ask you this
without asking you specifically I didn't
know about that oh is years later what
it comes out right more and more every
year so let me ask you so obviously
Bobby is it Farrell Ferrell Bobby from
Bonilla the way he performs you can't
teach a guy to perform that last week
comes in the way he looks he just looks
like so later you know he's got the one
hand you need a guy like that to be a
face right you can't teach that to shy
guy saying go move like him you can't
teach somebody to move like Rob or have
the background that you have the looks
that you guys have to get up there but
going back you know the names of some
people that have done this right you
know some other names that's not just
Bonilla more you are not lost are these
big names that you know of that if if
you were to share the names we would say
you've got to be kidding me
obvious suddenly it came out I just
don't want to know I know that there's
some that we don't know about that is
the industry knows about or know the
ones that I've come out they've come up
people know about it yeah yeah yeah okay
now most of it came came public even I
grew up with some of those tribes like
really it was like but he it came out
like some of them came out like three
years ago I was like wow so it was a
common practice it was because you know
those those teams are working in France
you know you had you know professional
teams working making music and they
wanted to compete because London America
was not the focus England was the focus
first step at that time that's right so
they had in order to to land on an
English chart
no way the French language would make it
no way so it had to be in English so
these people like Franklin knew this so
yeah that was the point even if you
wanted to go internationally think about
that like let me ask you you're not fair
okay you're John Doe
okay but you know every detail that you
guys went through you know all the
details that you and Rob even some of
the stuff you've never disclosed
publicly cry right I'm talking all of it
behind closed doors do you think what
was done there should be accepted as art
or do you think it wasn't right what you
guys did remember John Doe looking and
he has access to all the information
that you have do you think what you guys
did was right it's a part of art or no
it was an art I just have question how
can I read the thing is everything you
know what I'm f
I know what you're asking mmm it's tough
because you know those if I look at
Robin fab they were manipulated into
into doing this you know so me looking
at it from the outside is it art
looking back stuff question
tell me jury was it wrong well we can't
look at it like that you know when
premeditated it is wrong those two kids
were trapped in doing this so looking at
it from the you know from a distance
is it art yeah it's it's a form of art
it's twisted though you know but let's
not forget that they were they were
human beings at the center of it all
they were used and abused and when the
time came
thrown to the wolves me and you and Rob
yeah like nothing it costs Rob's life at
32 years old exact was suicidal multiple
times went to rehab ten plus times sugar
so you went to rehab is what what you
recovered for every color for me but uh
you know to to go back to you or to your
answer when I look at it with all the
the information that I have and you ask
me whether or not it's a form of art I
don't know it's doubtful form of art
maybe to Frank to him maybe it's a sport
you know it's like to him it's art I can
say that you understand him is like
listen I'm gonna make that happen
he didn't know was gonna be that big you
see well he didn't know he was gonna be
that big now I wouldn't you know though
but that boney I mean those guys got big
hundred-plus no no no no he D know
because we I remember we if I recall my
memory bank
it wasn't no one knew only after after
after a certain single after maybe a
second single then it became possibly
apparent but from the get-go it wasn't a
parent you know you know how I so for
him like I said yeah maybe for him it's
maybe a form of art to him but it's it's
it's to you
can't answer it can you again I can't
because it's you know I was a sinner III
I know those guys I was that guy you
know and and in the pain the the the
effect the consequences to that so can
we call it art if you're gonna if if the
people at the center of this painting if
he's gonna take the life of one in order
to achieve this painting in the name of
art you know you know how I process this
let me share with you our process this
because you know like when a life's got
the vanilla ice has been on our channel
before okay can we interview no and what
was his challenge his challenge wasn't
that you know he was lip sync or his
channel his challenge was ten tenten
tenten tenten tenten tenten da that's
still old from Queen right that's right
listen to me the song under pressure or
something like that right and I might
say he says no mine is tenten tenten a
tenten tenten tenten tenten tenten so he
says that last time we didn't have okay
so he got heat for that he went up came
down it lasted 21 days for him by the
way he lasted two years
for him alas of 21 days oh wow 21 days
21 days right I mean who doesn't
remember this play that funky music
white boy you know a vanilla ice ice
your stuff you know everybody remembers
that song every night today you listen
to it you're like listen it's a pretty
cool song I don't know why that stopped
his momentum and to do it was still art
you would still practice an art now what
you guys did it's not vanilla ice cuz
let's set that part of set what he did
to me with you
I don't you didn't steal anyone's
Charles knew what he was doing and
Charles I'm assuming got paid yeah yes
okay you knew you weren't singing and
you got paid Frank knew what was going
on and he got paid you guys didn't
commit a crime
you were actors so so so I'm trying to
see I mean I I understand because I
don't know what Charles looks like the
only reason I know what Charles looks
because I was studying you so when I
looked at everything like oh that's what
he writes I : strike and Frank didn't
see them as being face of a Pam you know
no one's gonna because he says something
like you guys can't sing but those guys
cannot be on the cover he Frank seems
like he was pretty cold the way he said
it he was pretty cool because the thing
is like he never tested it
he never tested you guys who sing like
you were saying in Robert Ackley but but
to go back to it that's what I'm asking
you know how they say this actors a
triple threat you know what a triple
threat yeah of course somebody I can
sing - nice - old Hollywood okay
somebody that can sing dance and act
yeah
if you look at yours you guys would be a
double on these four songs now obviously
later on you said we're taking singing
lessons and even you performed the song
will you perform it you got a voice it's
not like you've got a great voice I'm
still me or not seen y'all I saw you on
Arsenio Hall yeah I saw that as Y so I
even saw an hour sitting hall at the end
told the audiences rob was pissed off he
said I wanna kick your ass if you don't
let me play cuz Rob was trying to get
him to perform I thought it was fun but
you actually can't sing
it's not like you cannot sing so but I
look at this and I still look at it as a
form of art because you know how to
perform and you know how to act in those
four songs it's not your voice so you're
not the singer right so maybe you were a
double threat you were not a triple
threat it's interesting to to look at it
like that I'm giving you john doe's
perspex yeah John this perspective man
that's why I ask you to see what you
would say then I'm even in my
perspective yeah to see how it's viewed
because listen my kids this week so once
we know you know where we got into
calendar you come into town I play the
song for my son Dylan and Sena Dylan and
Patrick and they said can you play it
again yeah I plug it can you play it
again so once we get onto something we
want to put a soft plate like 50 times
good morning 6:30 they wake up and I see
my six-year-old son
girl you know it's true ooh what are you
doing singing good girl you know it's
like baby you know Dylan was thinking
Milli Vanilli today girl you know it's
strong what's a great song it's six
years old six years old awesome
generation and I'd say he's also guide
girls love him because he's got the look
he's always been a charmer with women so
he's gonna probably play a lot of songs
like that for women looking back my
biggest question for you is the final we
got a few minimum more minutes here my
last question for you is you know all of
us have humiliating moments everybody
right oh my gosh I went up to the girl I
like hey I want to take you out I would
never date a guy like you oh my gosh it
stays with you she rejected forever
forever right yeah yeah you go and you
you know tell the sky off you know the
hell with you you push him he punches
you knocks you out in front of a hundred
people in school everyone knows you as
the guy that got knocked up by Billy
right humiliating forever you're
supposed to win the championship in high
school you lose it in front your dad he
made the first game for the rest your
life you remember I lost the game I said
I want my dad and my grandpa would
understand everybody as humiliating
moments right yeah most people don't
know how to recover from it right it's
not easy okay and no matter how many
humiliating moments we've had that we
put it together I don't think it comes
close to the public scrutiny you guys
got so the heart I want to ask you is
the following
here's the part I want to ask you I
don't know what it's like to go to the
point where you have a you know a whole
strategy where the girls come meet at
the base then after the base somebody is
filtering them and saying hey I know Rob
likes butts or you know you know fav
likes tall girls his legs he likes to
bring Demma he likes a nice face he like
okay then go and do them okay I don't
know what it's like to party the way you
guys are I don't know what it is to go
everyone people style oh my gosh look at
the voice it's so good I don't know what
it is to be in the limo girl you know
it's true next station girl you know
it's true next station
no not many people know what it feels
like to be that person okay then comes
to fall Rob couldn't handle it
it was tough on him right and a lot of
it is deeper for Rob Rob is not here
it's not fair to me for me to ask the
question for you to guess because you
know his dad was an Air Force mom was a
very attractive woman they meet then
they give him to adoption somebody else
take some family that German family
wants
this comes out that even family wanted
to kind of distance himself a little bit
from Rob's or Rob kind of feels isolated
along the only person he has in his life
is who you nobody else like a brother to
me younger brother so he ends up
whatever the autopsy is you know some
say suicide some say drugs all this
stuff you know the one person he had in
his life who actually was his sister she
was also adopted blood no adopted as
well adopted
yeah so she was still there with him she
she she wished she was a big part of his
life if she stole around to but she's
still around today yeah interesting
so she was sort about helping him get
out of it yeah she was the anchor for a
long time that's good you given her
credit I'm sure she's gonna see this but
you you were able to distance yourself
from and I saw one part where you said I
didn't leave the house I'd go shopping
late at night because I didn't just want
to go you know shop on when everybody
was so you kind of stayed in your place
for a couple years
what was your method of recovery after
all this madness to get yourself to be
where you are today were you're smiling
you're happy you seem very fulfilled
you're performing your practice and your
music your deejaying
you're out there working on projects you
got stuff going on in France you got
stuff that's going on you're looking
forward to the future yeah how do you go
from that fall to being where you are
today
well I would say that the one ingredient
to this is music and music like I told
you when I was a kid was my lifeline you
know and through the years I've grown
closer and closer to music and when it
was when everything's on the chips fell
I said you know I don't want to love my
life without music I don't see it so
gotta go back to the drawing board
that's number one learn how to write a
song so number one is passion passion is
about your passion go back to your
passion and work on your skills work on
those skills day in day out songwriting
playing guitar
understanding production go full-on and
that's where I lived a very lonely life
but I had no problem I'm a loner so but
I knew that time was was of the essence
and the amount of time that I had to
invest in myself I hoped my instincts
the voices saying it could it could
maybe work we don't know so I worked on
fate you know fate just pushing myself
but seeing progress when you see
progress just like you know basketball
player you know I'm like you know you
you work for a year you make a plan okay
you're three throw is good now you get
the three-pointer
you know what you angle you know you
know what part of the court to use
that's your best pot footwork is on and
that's what I've been doing through the
years working on on all that working on
my skills or is performing some writing
producing and now producing some of my
music playing industry look at you now
when you see them have the completely
forgot about it and they don't bring it
up and it's just kind of like doing
business with the new fad yeah there are
people that are totally excited about
joining forces with me because the thing
is being underestimated is one of the
best place to be I agree I love it I've
told me I subscribe on that because
meeting the hype very few can meet up
the hype so now when the expectations
are so low and you surpass them then I
could play route that you could play it
into your favor in a major way and you
can build up on that and then certainly
you can really create something very
solid because after all those years you
know I've learned a few things and a few
things are you know there's music and
there's music business and the business
of music and music is that the only the
only thing that I'm after I've been
developing a few things through my
journey you're excited about life I'm
excited about life what are you looking
forward to I'm looking forward to become
who I'm supposed to be and creativity
being my sword will allow me to do that
my creativity my discipline those two
for anyone out there you know creativity
in anything you do
even for your new business one of the
reason why you became so successful is
because of your creativity you drive and
focus so when you have those few factors
into play and you play with them and you
keep them close you know and you keep on
challenging yourself and daily well
action equal reaction there's gonna be
results and out of that you take it you
take that ball further into you know
making that those you know those three
throw or whether they're maybe so
getting closer to where you want to be
do you feel like you've already
experienced redemption or not yet I
think I have you think you have yeah
yeah so if nothing else happens for the
rest of your life everything else that
you plan on it blowing like going baked
nothing goes big you feel like you've
already redeem yourself from what store
your today yeah how do you measure that
I measure that by the love I receive
from people you know we live in a
different world now believing that
there's no middle man between the fence
and me and if anyone goes and peeks at
what people are talking about when my
name is brought up because my goal was
to make sure that movie nearly the word
the words really nearly meant when you
fall you stand back up I think that's so
it's an objective but that's a beautiful
thing when you think about Milligan
early when you fall you come by the way
just to gather curiosity do you listen
to those songs yourself like do you
enjoy listening to them I perform them
all the time do you listen to it outside
of you performer do you listen to the
songs but I you know the thing is when
you when you were
like some right like me there's many
ways of listening you know and sometime
I'm surprised like girl I'm gonna miss
you is one is one of them that that I
listen to because the fact that it's
it's a mood
it's classic song you know it's got that
hip-hop kind of the groove he's got that
hip-hop feel classic you know I need
love LL Cool J flavor and you got those
gospel chords at the leather place on
top of it again
puzzle the foundation and it almost has
this religious feel to it that grabs you
you know especially women gravitate
towards that one and I said day in day
out when I'm on stage years and years
later he's just collapsing emotionally
you know it just grabs you and you know
I'm gonna miss you yeah cuz that's your
favorite one out of all of them so one
of my favorites and actually one of the
most successful one John Davis wait on
that yeah grunting I'm gonna miss you is
powerful to gin is it solid yeah oh my
gosh you know I mean listen ain't those
the three the one baby give me your
number they needed to fit my number
don't forget my number to me that's top
three to me is you know those those to
blame it on the rain is probably going
to rain you know it's probably gonna be
girl I'm gonna miss you and Benny in
Europe in America it's different a
different story yeah you know when I was
in Europe I mean these songs were played
on everything that we were doing
everything when I was in Germany
everything was really one everything was
about that yeah everything David
Hasselhoff was big at that time because
he had some hits but many but many was
like everywhere at that time well you
know I appreciate you for coming out
he's pleasure and I got a lot of respect
for you man a lot of respect it was
great talk because the chemistry was
different yeah oh you do things
differently you know and I like that and
it's always fun to be challenged to beat
because you know any conversation like
like this one like I said action equal
reaction
so I leave just like the people are
going to wash it though while watching
it
we'll get something out of that but out
of this conversation also gets something
out of you as well so it's it's yeah but
it's I don't think there are many people
like you in the world that has the story
that you I think you have a one of a
kind it's one of a kind story yeah yeah
and I think that you know things happen
for a reason and I stand for the dream
and if everything that happened to me is
to bring me back and show people listen
anything is possible if I fail and the
conditions were harsh I went through
storm I went through hell I came back
stronger it's possible to come back out
stronger but make sure that you face
your fears and demons it's very
important now that people bring it up is
it just water off your back like it
doesn't do anything to you when people
bring it up does not hurt you and ounce
I'm fine with it when they go out and
rob then I get a little it's a little
because you know he's like you said I
like the way you said it you said
Robbie's not his advantage self he can't
really answer those questions and it's
true in some time when they go after him
I'm like huh it just you know though the
scars kind of like you know that you
think sometime are healed and they're
fresh suddently you know wow that that
that tells us how close the two of you
guys were together yeah we were close
that tells us and the fact that he left
so abruptly but I knew that this day
possibly could happen because of what I
was doing you know he lost his foothold
to to life you know and but he was
dealing with other things that I was
dealing with my my stronghold my hanker
was music there was a goal and I was
lucky to meet Kim Marlowe my manager who
helped me should grow up my mountain you
know a total speed but the turtle never
fails progress is that yet I love the
way you put a number one go back
passion number to improve in a skill
that has to do with your passion yes
number three Bank on your faith have
faith that things are gonna get better
and number four keep making progress no
matter what speaking your matter you
might do that never too late it's never
too late it's gonna work itself out well
I want to hear from you guys on what
your biggest takeaway is you can message
below and comment and tell us what you
took away from it are you on Twitter or
more on Instagram which I am on
Instagram guy for sure because of your
active your active on Instagram very
active I'm also very active on YouTube
because it has a vlog and I have a vlog
every weekends that I do in French in
English and I cover I freestyle it
sometime I do Q&A but it's mostly what
happened that week I'm gonna charge
right now in France mm-hmm things are
moving up we're gonna be totally done in
two majors to take it worldwide so
things are great and my thing is because
of what I've won gone through like a
song could change your life back in the
days like Redemption song Bob Marley
mm-hmm special songs and we don't have
that anymore
like how songs had that impact and I
look like you know it's a way for me of
giving back to I'm not preaching I'm
just telling people listen those are the
tools that I'm using check it out
try it out and see what it does for you
we are gonna put the links to both of
them below Instagram message him go on
Instagram the center of a message and
tell him what you took away from this
we'll put the link below and also
YouTube channel yeah to his channel and
subscribe to his channel
appreciate and thank them again brother
thank you for coming out coming out yes
I really enjoy really really a pleasure
for coming out thank you and you yo
you're awesome because you know the one
thing is when you do interviews people
some people wave like you know want to
talk about body language you hear you're
right there you're in the moment because
in the moment that's where things happen
so when you're aware and you're awake
the sleeper in you is gonna wake up and
think is gonna change I agree
come on man thank you interesting story
right with
I don't know about your age but if you
remember milli vanilli you got to be in
your mid-thirties and up or your parents
listen to me live and I like I listen to
this song next to my kids here but it's
great to hear the story of a rise and a
fault and how do you redeem yourself
when you have a public humiliating
moment like he had and it doesn't get
bigger than the one he had so everybody
can take something away from this one
and if you enjoyed today's interview I
got another one I want you to watch
that's what Vanilla Ice I sat down with
him a year year and a half ago and Scott
it's another great story so if you
haven't watch it click over here to
watch us and if you've not subscribed to
this channel click over here subscribe
thanks for watching everybody
take care bye bye
[Music]